THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS.
BATES.
BELL.
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible] ZERO CHIANG.
DODD.
THE ROUTE SO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROW [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
WITH SO -- TITLE [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
WHY CASKEY [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WILK.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH
THE MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS BE ON
THE REAL AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RISE WE'LL BE LEAD IN
PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON BY
CHAPLAIN SISTER MICHELLE GORMAN.
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING AND WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE BY SENATOR
GROVE.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN.
WE COULD START WITH THE PLEDGE
OF ALLEGIANCE THAT'S OKAY.
SO LET US REMEMBER THIS WE'RE
ALWAYS IN GOD'S PRESENCE.
GOD OF SURPRISES.
YOUR CALL US FROM THE NARROWNESS
OF OUR TRADITIONS TO NEW WAYS OF
BEING HUMAN.
FROM THE CAPTIVITY IS OF OUR
CULTURE. TO CREATIVE WITNESS FOR
JUSTICE.
FROM THE SMALLNESS OF OUR
HORIZONS TO THE MAGNIFICENCE OF
YOUR VISION.
CLEAR THE WAY ANNA'S YOUR PEOPLE.
THOSE WE MIGHT INVITE OTHERS TO
FREEDOM AND RENEWED FAITH.
GOD OF SURPRISES YOUR CALL US
FROM PREOCCUPATION WITH THEIR
OWN HISTORIES AND HURT. TO DAILY
TASKS OF PEACEMAKING.
FROM PRIVILEGE ANDPROTOCOL. TO
PARTNERSHIP AND PILGRIMAGE.
FROM ISOLATION AND INSULARITY.
TO INCLUSIVE COMMUNITY.
CLEAR THE WAY ANNA SEARED PEOPLE.
BUT WE MIGHT INVITE OTHERS TO
WHOLENESS AND INTEGRITY.
HOLY TRANSFORMING SPIRITS.
YOU CALL US FROM FEAR TO
FAITHFULNESS.
FROM CLUTTER TO CLARITY.
FROM A DESIRE TO CONTROL TO
DEEPER TRUSTS.
FROM THE REFUSAL TO LOVE TO A
READINESS TO RISK.
CLEAR THE WAY ON US YOUR PEOPLE.
BUT WE MIGHT ALL KNOWN THE
BEAUTY AND POWER OF SPREADING
YOUR GOOD NEWS OF LOVE A MAN.
COLLEAGUES I'D LIKE TO REMIND MY
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES THAT WE
SERVE A GOD OF GRACE.
AND THEN I'D LIKE TO ALL INVITES
YOU TO SALUTE OUR NATION'S FLAG.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
[inaudible]
AND SHE AND INVISIBLE.
WHEN HIS SISTER MICHELLE?
MEMBERS WE WILL START WITH
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
SENATOR PAN ARE YOU READY ARE
YOUR GUESTS HERE.
OKAY MEMBERS IF I CAN ASK
EVERYONE TO BE SEATED.
SO THAT WE CAN.
CELEBRATE API HERITAGE MONTH
.
WHEN EVERYONE IS SEATED WILL BE
ABLE TO GET STARTED?
VERY GOOD SENATOR PAN MISTER
SECRETARY ARE YOU READY TO TAKE
UP A C. R. THIRTY MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
THIRTY BY SENATOR PAN RELATIVE
TO ASIAN AND ACIFIC ISLANDER
AMERICAN HERITAGE MONTH.
CENTER PAN OF THE PROTONS TO ASK
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS IT IS AN HONOR 2% STR
THIRTY TO RECOGNIZE MAY TWENTY
NINETEEN AS ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER AMERICAN HERITAGE MONTH.
THROUGHOUT THIS MONTH WE
CELEBRATE THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF A
P. I. A.'S TO OUR NATION AND
PARTICULARLY TO CALIFORNIA.
DESPITE THE VARIETY OF
COMMUNITIES THAT MAKE UP TO
EIGHTY AYE A COMMUNITY ALL OF
THEIR STORIES ARE TIED TOGETHER
BY THEIR STRENGTH AND COURAGE
THAT WAS NEEDED TO OVERCOME
CHALLENGES THEY FACED HERE IN
THE UNITED STATES.
THEIR STRENGTH AND PERSISTENCE
HELPED SPARK ONE OF THE BIGGEST
LABOR MOVEMENTS AND FOUGHT
AGAINST THE ALIEN LAND LAW TO
PREVENT IT SOUTH ASIAN AMERICAN
FARMERS FROM OWNING FARMS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY.
AGE LED THEM TO BE ONE THE MOST
DECORATED US MILITARY UNITS IN
HISTORY WHEN THE JAPANESE
AMERICANS FOUGHT IN WORLD WAR
TWO WHILE THEIR FAMILIES WERE
INCARCERATED BACK HOME.
DESPITE THESE STRUGGLES API A
COMMUNITIES DEDICATED THEIR
LIVES TO THEIR FAMILIES TO OUR
STATE AND TO OUR NATION.
THIS MONTH'S COMMEMORATION OF
API A HERITAGE MONTH SERVES AS A
REMINDER OF THE RICH CULTURE
THAT MAKES OUR GREAT STATE.
AS THE MANY DIVERSE API A
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
CELEBRATE.
AT AYE A HERITAGE MONTH THIS MAY
I HOPE THAT YOU'LL JOIN A TI A
COMMUNITIES IN YOUR DISTRICT TO
CELEBRATE OUR PROUD HISTORY AND
HERITAGE.
SO PLEASE JOIN ME IN
COMMEMORATING ASIAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER AMERICAN HERITAGE MONTH
BY SUPPORTING THAT'S YOUR THIRTY
AYE SPECIALLY ASK FOR NIGHT THAT.
THANK YOU CENTER PAN MEMBERS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CENTER
CHIANG.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES I WOULD LIKE TO
THINK CENTER PAN FOR INTRODUCING
YES YOUR THIRTY AS A MEMBER OF
THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
AND CULTURE THE DRAWING API
CAUCUS.
I AM PROUD TO REPRESENT SUCH A
DIVERSE COMMUNITY ORANGE COUNTY
HAS THE THIRD LARGEST ASIAN
AMERICAN POPULATION IN THE
COUNTRY.
AND THE SAME THING YOU WERE
VALLEY HAS MORE ASIAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER RESIDENTS AND
IN FORTY TWO STATES.
THEY CONTINUE TO ENRICH OUR
COMMUNITIES AND OUR VALUABLE
CONTRIBUTORS TO OUR SOCIETY IN
EVERY ASPECT.
I AM HONORED TO JOIN MY
COLLEAGUE IN COMMENDING ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDERS IN MY DISTRICT
IN CROSS CALIFORNIA WITH A C. R.
THIRTY WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE BOOK AS WELL.
THANK YOU CENTER CHIANG CENTER
GROVE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I TOO
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE GOOD
SENATOR FOR INTRODUCING EASIER
THIRTY AND I'M HONORED TO STAND
HERE TODAY IN RECOGNITION OF
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER AMERICAN
HERITAGE MONTH AS THE SENATE
MINORITY LEADER.
THIS MEANT CELEBRATES A CAN
TREAT CONTRIBUTIONS OF ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT OUR NATION THE THEME
OF THIS MONTH IS UNITE OUR
MISSION BY ENGAGING IN EACH EACH
OTHER.
IS THIS FOR BUSINESS TO POLITICS
ASIAN AMERICANS HAVE CONTRIBUTED
TO THE RICH HISTORY OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE UNITED STATES
IN FACT THE FIRST ASIAN AMERICAN
EVER TO BE ELECTED IN PUBLIC
SERVICE.
WAS U. S. SENATOR HIRAM FONG
FROM.
NINETEEN FIFTY NINE TO NINETEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN SIT SENATE MR FONG
WAS REPUBLICAN WHO ADVOCATED FOR
CIVIL AND VOTING RIGHTS
LEGISLATION.
CURRENTLY ELAINE CHAO THE U. S.
SECRETARY OF TRANSPORTATION IS
THE FIRST ASIAN AMERICAN WOMAN
AND THE FIRST CHINESE AMERICAN.
IN U. S. HISTORY TO EVER BE
APPOINTED BY IN A PRESIDENT'S
CABINET.
HERE IN THE SENATE WE HAVE
SENATOR LING LING CHIANG ON OUR
SIDE OF THE AISLE SENATOR CHIANG
IS THE FIRST TIME WHEN HE'S BORN
LEGISLATOR ELECTED TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE IN THE
ONLY ASIAN AMERICAN WOMAN IN THE
JOINT API LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS.
THIS MONTH IN MAY IS CHOSEN FOR
THE CELEBRATION TO COMMEMORATE
THE IMMIGRTION OF THE FIRST
JAPANESE AMERICAN TO THE UNITED
STATES ON MAY SEVENTH NINETEEN
EIGHTEEN FORTY THREE AND TO MARK
THE ANNIVERSARY OF AT IN.
EXCUSE ME TO MARK THE
ANNIVERSARY OF THE COMPLETION OF
THE TRANSCONTINENTAL RAILROAD ON
MAY TENTH.
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE THIS MORNING
WE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO GO --
TO THE S. THE MEDICINE FOR
MANSION AND THEY WERE --
INTERVIEW SCENE AND HAVING A
CELEBRATION ON RECORD ON
RECOGNIZING A PAPA WHICH IS AN
ORGANIZATION THAT BENEFITS AND
HAS.
ASIAN AMERICANS ELECTED TO
OFFICE IT WAS TRULY AN HONOR TO
BE HERE AND I THINK YOU OFFER
PARTICIPATING IN THAT AND I
REALLY ENJOYED ALL THE HISTORY
THAT WAS.
PORTRAYED THERE SO COLLEAGUES I
JUST ASK YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU SENATOR GROWTH SENATOR
NIELSEN.
BETTERPRESENT LAYS GERMAN THE
SENATE.
SOME OF YOU.
ACTUALLY.
HAVE PARTICIPATED WITH THIS
ORGANIZATION.
WE MET WITH TODAY AND THE
GOVERNOR ATTENDED A POP. FOR
THEY PROVIDE.
INTERNS ONE OF THEIR KEY
PROGRAMS OF A POP UP.
IS AN INTERNSHIP.
IN A SCHOLARSHIP.
AS WELL AS A VOTER.
FOR AND IT IS TO EMPOWER.
API [inaudible]
INDIVIDUALS [inaudible]
THE SOCIETY.
BUT ANOTHER.
WONDERFUL THING ABOUT THIS
ORGANIZATION
IS THAT A PAPA IS ALL INCLUSIVE.
ALL ETHNICITIES.
ARE INVOLVED.
IN OUR ACTIVITIES.
AND I SAY OUR BECAUSE I'M ONE OF
THE ORIGINAL SIX FOUNDERS WHO
SET DOWN A LITTLE OFFICE YEARS
AGO.
AND DECIDED WE COULD DO
SOMETHING GREATER. TO EMPOWER
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDERS.
NOW THERE ARE MANY.
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
ORGANIZATIONS.
THROUGHOUT AMERICA.
AND A PAPA NOW IS NATIONWIDE.
BUT THERE ARE MANY ORGANIZATIONS.
THEY ALL WORK TOGETHER.
AND ONE OF THE GREAT THINGS THAT
WE FOCUSED ON AND HAVE FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS [inaudible]
A PAPA [inaudible]
IS THE UNION PACIFIC RAILROAD.
AND THE PARTICIPATION.
OF ALL OF THOSE FROM ASIA.
WHO BUILT THAT RAIL?
THROUGH THOSE INCREDIBLE SIERRA
MOUNTAINS [inaudible]
WHICH WITHOUT.
THERE WOULD BE NOT MUCH OF A
CALIFORNIA.
TODAY.
ANOTHER REASON. TO CELEBRATE
[inaudible]
THIS MONTH.
THANK YOU CENTER NIELSEN CENTER
BRADFORD.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT ON
BEHALF THE LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF S. C. R..
THIRTY AND THEY PAY I COMMUNITY
MUCH LIKE THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY HAS SUFFERED.
MUCH -- SIGNIFICAN
DISCRIMINATION AND PREJUDICE IN
THIS COUNTRY FROM THE INTERMENT
OF JAPANESE STORE WAR WR TO TO
THE EXPLOITATION OF CHINESE AS
ARE SENATOR FROM CAME AS STATED.
IN BUILDING A ROLL WROTE.
BUT DESPITE MUCH OF THE
PREJUDICE AND DISCRIMINATION
THAT THE API COMMUNITY OUT SPACE
THEY CONTINUE TO PROSPER.
AND BUILD UPON A GREAT HERE TO
TO MAKE GREAT CONTRIBUTIONS TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO.
AS C. R. THIRTY SERVES AS A
REMINDER THAT OUR DIVERSITY IS
WHAT STRENGTHENS US HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER BRADFORD
SENATOR DURAZO.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU MATT GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD MORNING.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR.
I RISE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF A C.
R..
THIRTY IN MY DISTRICT ALONE.
MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE IDENTIFIES
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER THEIR
CONTRIBUTION TO OUR STATE IS
EVIDENT IN THE VIBRANT
NEIGHBORHOODS.
THAT PRESERVE THEIR CULTURE
LANGUAGES AND TRADITIONS.
LOS ANGELES IS INCREDIBLY UNIQUE
ON MY DISTRICT AS IT IS HOME TO
SEVEN HISTORIC ISN'T ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUNITIES.
LITTLE TOKYO CHINATOWN TIGHT
TOWN KOREATOWN HISTORIC FILIPINO
TOWN LITTLE BANGLADESH AND
LITTLE ARMENIA.
THE TAPESTRY OF ALL OF THESE
CULTURES IS INTERVAL WOULD ONE
WHAT THE OTHER AND EVEN WITH
OTHER ETHNIC GROUPS LIKE LATINOS.
THIS TAPESTRY HAS LED TO KOREAN
AND VIETNAMESE TOPLESS OR
MEXICAN SUSHI.
NOW TO SOME THAT MAY SOUND
SACRILEGIOUS BUT IT IS THE
BEAUTIFUL REALITY OF DIVERSITY.
ASIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDERS HAVE
MADE A PERMANENT MARK ON OUR
CITY FROM DISTINGUISHING
THEMSELVES IN THE ARTS IN
ACADEMIA TRY BUSINESS AND
COMMUNITIES.
LET'S TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
LEARN MORE ABOUT THEIR RICH
HISTORY.
THEIR PUSH FOR CIVIL RIGHTS FOR
EVERYONE AND THERE NOTABLE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS THAT HAVE MADE
OUR GREAT GREAT STATE I RISE AND
I I URGE AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER DORADO CENTER
STERN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE
ON BEHALF OF LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS.
NOT ONLY DOES THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY API COMMUNITY HAVE IN
COMMON THE HISTORY OF OF STRONG
WOMEN LEADING FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES.
WE ALSO HAVE A SHARED HISTORY OF
PERSECUTION AND I WANTED TO KNOW
TO FEW CHAPTERS OF HISTORY THAT.
PARTICULAR REFLECT THAT.
THE API COMMUNITY DURING THE
HOLOCAUST WHEN CHINA WAS ONE OF
THE ONLY COUNTRIES THAT DID NOT
RESTRICT THE MIGRATION.
WELCOME MORE THAN TWENTY
THOUSAND JEWS WHO FLEADH FROM
GERMANY AUSTRIA POLAND IRAQ AND
RUSSIA.
CHEN HI SPECIFICALLY DID NOT
REQUIRE VISAS.
AND LEAD TO SOME HARROWING
INITIATIVES THROUGH THEIR
DIPLOMATIC EFFORTS TO SAVE TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF LIVES.
AS THE WAR CONTINUED AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER NINETY SIXTY SIX
BEGAN JAPANESE INTERMENT IN
AMERICA.
CHOOSE IN TURN.
RECOGNIZE THE STRIKING
SIMILARITIES BETWEEN THE CRIMES
AGAINST OUR OWN PEOPLE AND THE
ISOLATION AND IMPRISONMENT OF
JAPANESE AMERICANS.
JEWISH ORGANIZATIONS SINCE THEN
HAVE BECOME DEEPLY INVOLVED IN
DEVELOPING ALLIANCES HERE AT
HOME TO FIGHT PREJUDICE BOTH
REGIONALLY AND NATIONALLY.
WHETHER IT'S RABBI IRVING RIGHT
CHURCH.
OF SAN FRANCISCO'S TEMPLE ALLEY
MON A NEW.
WAS A FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE
PACIFIC COAST COMMITTEE ON
NATIONAL SECURITY IN FAIR PLAY
ONE OF THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENTS.
LEADING ADVOCATES TO AND
JAPANESE INTERMENT.
OR RABBI EDGAR MAGNIN OF LOS
ANGELES CAN LOS ANGELES'S
CONGREGATION BUT NAY BRIT.
UC BERKELEY PROVOST MONTEREAU
DEUTSCHE LEVI STRAUSS EXECUTIVE
DANIEL COSTLY AND ANOTHER
PROMINENT USE WHO ARE ALSO
INVOLVED IN THE FAIR PLAY
COMMITTEE.
LA LAWYERS AL WE'RE IN AND FRED
OPENED WORKED ON JAPANESE
AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES CASES
THAT WENT ALL THE WAY UP TO THE
SUPREME COURT.
AFTER THE WAR THE JAPANESE
AMERICAN CITIZENS LEAGUE JOINED
A COALITION WITH LEADING JEWISH
ORGANIZATIONS TO BUILD INTER
RACIAL COALITIONS.
AND WORK TOGETHER TO REPEAL
BACKWARDS LAN LAWS AND
NATURALIZATION BANDS.
OUR HISTORY DEMONSTRATES THE
NECESSITY IN STANDING TOGETHER.
IN THE WACO TRAGEDY HORN
RESURRECTION FOR DECADES WE HAVE
FOUGHT ALONGSIDE EACH OTHER.
THE WORK TO DISMANTLE THE
PARADIGMS OF HATE. TO REPLACE
BIGOTRY IN IGNORANCE WITH
TOLERANCE AND UNDERSTANDING.
THIS API HERITAGE MONTH WE HONOR
THE SHARED EXPERIENCES OF OUR
PAST.
AND CONTINUED ALLY SHIP TO
CREATE A MORE JUST WORLD IN THE
FUTURE.
WITH PROFOUND RESPECT AND
ADMIRATION FOR THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER COMMUNITY HIGHER JULIE
AND I VOTE ON ESSIE ARTHUR.
THANK YOU SENATOR STERN SEEING
NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
CENTER PAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS I WANNA THANK ALL MY
GOOD FRIENDS AND COLLEAGUES HERE
IN STATE CENTER FOR YOUR VERY.
KIND SUPPORT OF WORDS OF THIS
RESOLUTION -- I WOULD -- POINT
OUT THAT -- THIS RESOLUTION
COMMEMORATES PEOPLES WHO COME
FROM THE LARGEST OCEAN IN THE
WORLD AND THE LARGEST CONTINENT
IN THE WORLD.
WHAT THAT MEANS IS THAT -- WILL
THIS IS NOT A MONOLITHIC
COMMUNITY -- WELL CERTAINLY MANY
TIMES PEOPLE POINT TO THE MANY
SUCCESSES OF THE API A COMMUNITY
THE MODEL MINORITY MYTH IS OFTEN
ONE THAT COMES UP.
BUT POINT OUT THAT -- ACTUALLY --
MANY OF THE API A COMMUNITY
ACTUALLY LIVE IN EXTREME POVERTY
FACT UNFORTUNATELY OUR COMMUNITY
STRUGGLES THE FACT THAT WE HAVE
THE GREATEST INCOME DISPARITY OF
ANY.
ETHNIC GROUP SOMETHING THAT WERE
CHALLENGED WITH OUR ALSO POINT
OUT THAT ACTUALLY WERE THE
FASTEST GROWING IMMIGRANT GROUP
IN FACT OVER HALF OF ALL APA
HERE IN CALIFORNIA ARE ACTUALLY
IMMIGRANTS THEMSELVES NOT JUST
CHILDREN IMMIGRANTS BUT
IMMIGRANTS THEMSELVES.
AND EVEN THOUGH AS WE TALK ABOUT
PASSING JUSTICES.
WE ALSO THINK ABOUT TODAY EVEN
TODAY WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
DEPORTATION OF CAMBODIAN
AMERICANS AND EVEN THE THREAT TO
TO DEPORT VIETNAMESE AMERICANS.
WHO CAME OVER AS -- BOTH PEOPLE
WHO'VE MADE MISTAKES AND YOUNG
ALIVE SO THE FIGHT CONTINUES.
AND I APPRECIATE AND THANK ALL
OF YOU WHO SPOKE OUT SUPPORT WE
NEED TO CONTINUE TO COME
TOGETHER -- IN OUR DIVERSITY NOT
ONLY IS THE API A COMMUNITY BUT
OF COURSE ACROSS ALL ETHNIC AND
RACIAL GROUPS HERE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
AND WITH THAT I HEARD AND I VOTE
ON SCR THIRTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER PAN MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
I BILL [inaudible]
I PORGES [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG.
BY DODD.
BY THE RAZA.
HI GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER AYE GROW.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
BY -- TITLE [inaudible]
I JACKSON BY JONES.
I LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE.
BY MITCHELL.
BY MORNING.
BY MORE LARK [inaudible]
I'M REAL [inaudible]
BY NELSON.
I PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH.
BY RUBIO.
I SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
I AM BURKE BY WORK OWSKI.
BY WINNER.
AYE WILK [inaudible]
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GORGEOUS BRADFORD HI.
I THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED SENATOR
PAN AND CENTER CHEIKH I BELIEVE
YOU HAVE SOME INTRODUCTIONS
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU AS THE JOINT API
CAUCUS BECAUSE HERE I AM EXCITED
TO JOIN SENATOR PAN TO RECOGNIZE
DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS OF THE API
COMMUNITY.
OUR GUESTS COME FROM VARIOUS
BACKGROUNDS WITH UNIQUE STORIES
THEY REPRESENT SOME OF THE BEST
AND BRIGHTEST IN THE APEC
COMMUNITY AND TODAY WE ARE HERE
TO CELEBRATE THEM.
THE FIRST PERSON I WOULD LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE A STEWART QUO.
OF REALLY QUICK STORY HE AND I
HAVE KNOWN EACH OTHER FOR ALMOST
TWENTY YEARS SO IT IS AN HONOR
FOR ME TO INTRODUCE HIM.
CIRCLE IS THE FOUNDING PRESIDENT
AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE.
LOS ANGELES FORMALLY KNOWN AS
THE ASIAN PACIFIC AMERICAN LEGAL
CENTER.
QUOTE WAS A NATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED LEADER AND EXPERT IN
RACE RELATIONS ASIAN AMERICAN
STUDIES NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
AND PHILANTHROPIES.
CIVIL RIGHTS AND LEGAL SERVICES
HE WAS NAMED A MACARTHUR
FOUNDATION FELLOW NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT BECOMING THE FIRST
ASIAN AMERICAN ATTORNEY AND
HUMAN RIGHTS ACTIVISTS RECEIVE
THIS HIGHLY.
PRESTIGIOUS RECOGNITION OFTEN
REFERRED TO AS A GENIUS GRANT.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN RECOGNIZING
CIRCLE FOR HIS DEDICATION TO
SOCIAL JUSTICE.
WELCOME YOUR CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
THAT'S RIGHT [inaudible]
GETTING.
SENATOR MA'AM THANK YOU OUR NEXT
AWARD -- RECOGNIZES THE
EXCELLENCE IN CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
JUDY KEY.
HERE.
JUDY IS A RETIRED MIDDLE SCHOOL
SCIENCE TEACHER WHO TAUGHT FOR
THREE DECADES WITH SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
HE SERVED ON THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON ASIAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER AMERICAN AFFAIRS
420-122-2016 SHE CONTINUES TO BE
AN ACTIVE VOLUNTEER SAN DIEGO
WORK ON ISSUE BASED ADVOCACY.
AND LANGUAGE SPECIFIC VOTER
REGISTRATION DRIVES AND
MENTORING NEW CANDIDATES WITH
GRASSROOTS CAMPAIGN SUPPORT.
PLEASE WELCOME A DUTY.
WELCOME YOUR CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE [inaudible]
EVERYBODY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT ANDREAS JAMES FEEBLE.
BORN IN THAILAND REYES IN
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA JAMES SEAFOOD
IS THE PFEFFER PRIOR OF CALM IS
THE ONLY.
MICHELIN STAR RESTAURANT OAKLAND
SINCE TWENTY TEN HAWK AFFAIRS
SAN FRANCISCO SERVING
TRADITIONAL LOTION.
THAI CUISINE IT'S OFF TO HAWKING
BIRD IN OAKLAND THE MEDICAL AREA
AND CASUAL CRUELTY I MEAN
BREWERY OLD CON IN WEST OAKLAND.
BEFORE OPENING CONOCEN HAWKER
FAIR SEE BLUE FORMALLY STUDY
THAT CALIFORNIA CULINARY ACADEMY
IN SAN FRANCISCO AND DEVELOP HIS
CRAFT AT NUMEROUS.
MICHELIN STAR RESTAURANTS AROUND
THE GLOBE NAMED BEST NEW CHEF IN
TWENTY TEN BY THE EPONYMOUS FOOD
AND WINE MAGAZINE THE BILL HAS
BEEN RECOGNIZED NOT ONLY FOR
SKILL AND DEDICATION TO THE
CULINARY ARTS.
BUT FOR REVIVING THE DINING
SCENE IS HOME TOWN OF OAKLAND.
I'LL BE MAKING SURE TRICKS TO
DROP BY JAMES RESTAURANT WHEN
I'M IN TOWN TO PLEASE JOIN ME IN
RECOGNIZING HIS A MEETING THAT
THAT DEDICATION TO THE CULINARY
ARTS.
WELCOME HERE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE [inaudible]
RIGHT.
LOTSA CHRISTIAN NINE IS OUR ON A
REEF IN FOR EXCELLENCE IN
PHILANTHROPYSHE IS A TECHNOLOGY
ENTREPRENEUR AND A START UP
INVESTOR AND ENGAGE
PHILANTHROPIST WHO HAS EXTENSIVE
EXPERIENCE ABOUT FINANCE AND
BUSINESS MANAGEMENT.
AS WELL AS HELPING BOTH YOUNG
COMPANIES AND NOT FOR PROFIT
SKILL INNOVATIVE IDEA TO DELIVER
IMPACT.
WHAT IS THE FOUNDER FORMER
PRESIDENT AND CURRENT CO CHAIR
OF THE AMERICAN INDIA FOUNDATION
AS WELL AS BOARD MEMBER OF THE
COMMONWEALTH CLUB IN SAN
FRANCISCO?
AND FELLOW OF THE AMERICAN
LEADERSHIP FORUM HER AREAS OF
FOCUS INCLUDE EDUCATION AT RISK
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES CANCER
RESEARCH AND ECONOMIC
EMPOWERMENT OF WOMEN.
THAT IS ALSO A SENIOR ADVISER
THE BOARD MEMBER OF THE LONDON
SCHOOL OF ECONOMICS SOUTH ASIA
CENTER PLEASE WELCOME THIS WAS
NOT AN WELCOME YOUR CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE
.
NEXT WE HAVE A DELL LIMB WAS
BORN AND RAISED IN MALAYSIA IS A
WRITER PRODUCER FOR FILM AND
TELEVISION.
SHOWS WRITTEN.
WRITTEN AND PRODUCED MULTIPLE
PRIMETIME TV DRAMAS INCLUDING
ONE TREE HILL PRIVATE PRACTICE
AND LETHAL WEAPON.
PERHAPS MOST NOTABLE NOTABLY SHE
WAS A CO WRITER FOR CRAZY RICH
ASIANS WHICH IS ONE OF ONE OF MY
FAVORITE MOVIES.
CURRENTLY SHE IS WRITING A
SCREENPLAY FOR DID A DISNEY
FEATURE ANIMATION JOIN ME IN
RECOGNIZING A DELL FOR HER
EXAMPLE YOU WORK IN ARTS AND
ENTERTAINMENT [inaudible]
CALIFORNIA FREAKY.
PAR EXCELLENCE IN JOURNALISM
AWARD GOES TO RICHARD LOUIS
RICHARD LEWIS A JOURNALIST WITH
A CAREER SPANNING THREE DECADES
HIS FOCUS HAS BEEN POLITICS AND
BREAKING NEWS ON OF ANYONE
HERE'S THE SUBJECT OF THE
STORIES -- HE IS CURRENTLY IN
ANCHORED AND THIS NBC AND NBC
NEWS HAS COVERED MANY OF THE
NETWORK'S MAJOR BREAKING STORIES
INCLUDING THE TWENTY TWELVE AND
TWENTY SIXTEEN ELECTIONS THE
WHITE HOUSE IMMIGRATION BAN
IMPLEMENTATION AND MORE.
BEFORE JOINING MSNBC LUIS SPENT
FIVE YEARS AT CNN WORLDWIDE WE
BECAME THE FIRST ASIAN AMERICAN
MALE IN AMERICA TO ANCHOR A
DAILY NATIONAL CABLE NETWORK
NEWS PROGRAM IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN LUIS RECEIVED
VARIOUS AWARDS FOR SUPPORTING
INCLUDING THE PEABODY AND EMMY
TEAM AWARDS DANNY ACE HUMAN AND
CIVIL RIGHTS AWARD AND OTHERS.
A CHINESE A PACIFIC ISLANDER
DESCENT RICHARD IS A FIRST
GENERATION AMERICAN HIS
BACKGROUND HAS A TWIST BECAUSE
HIS GRANDFATHER AN ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANT.
FILED FALSE PAPERS SON DOCUMENTS
SO RICHARDS REAL LAST NAME IS
ONE WELCOME.
TO EARLY.
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
LASTLY WE WOULD LIKE TO HONOR
MONA PASCAL [inaudible] FIVE
MOTOR SKILLS SERVES AS A POINT
APPOINTMENT SECRETARY IN THE
OFFICER OF GAP.
OFFICE OF GET GOVERNOR GAVIN
NEWSOM PRIOR TO HER POSITION
PASCO SERVED AS APPOINTMENT
SECRETARY IN THE OFFICER OF
GOVERNOR EDMUND G. BROWN JUNIOR.
CHIEF OF STAFF TO CALIFORNIA'S
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR JOHN
GARAMENDI AN ACTING LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR AFTER GARAMENDI WAS
ELECTED TO CONGRESS.
THIS MARKED THE FIRST TIME A
WOMAN ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER OR
FILIPINO AMERICANS SERVED IN
THIS ROLE.
PASCAL IS MOST PROUD OF HER WORK
MENTORING CALIFORNIA'S USED TO
BECOME MORE ACTIVE IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
THIS WORK INCLUDES FOUNDING THE
ASIAN PACIFIC YOUTH LEADERSHIP
PROJECT OF CALIFORNIA IN
ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO
BOOSTING ASIAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER YOUTH INVOLVEMENT IN
CALIFORNIA POLICY.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN RECOGNIZING
RECOGNIZING MONA PASCO FOR HER
TIRELESS WORK ETHIC AND
COMMITMENT TO IMPROVING THE
COMMUNITIES IN OUR GREAT STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
BUCCANEERS CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE
.
SENATOR CHIANG FOR WHAT PURPOSE
TO RISE SO JUST CLOSING REMARKS
THE PLEASE PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU FELLOW SENATORS AND
GUESTS FOR JOINING SENATOR PAT
AND MYSELF IN HONORING THE SEVEN
INDIVIDUALS THEY REPRESENT JUST
A SMALL FRACTION WHAT THE API
COMMUNITY BRINGS TO CALIFORNIA.
SO PLEASE JOIN ME ONE FINAL
ROUND OF APPLAUSE FOR
DISTINGUISHED GUESTS AND PLEASE
JOIN US FOR PICTURES WELL THANK
YOU
.
ALL RIGHT MEMBERS WE ARE STILL
UNDER PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
SENATOR WILK I BELIEVE YOU HAVE
A RESOLUTION TO PRESENT.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION TWENTY EIGHT
BY SENATOR WILK RELATIVE TO
PRADA REALLY SYNDROME AWARENESS
MONTH [inaudible]
SENATOR WILK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT
SENATE RESOLUTION TWENTY EIGHT
WHICH WILL RECOGNIZE MAY AS
PRIDE -- WILLI SYNDROME
AWARENESS MONTH.
PRADA WILLI SYNDROME IS A
COMPLEX GENETIC DISORDER FOR
WHICH WE CURRENTLY DO NOT HAVE A
CARE.
IT IS THANK YOU IT IS THE MOST
COMMONLY KNOWN GENETIC CAUSE OF
MORBID OBESITY SALLY FREQUENT
CAUSE OF DEATH IN IT IN AN
AFFECTED INDIVIDUAL.
PRADA WILLIE -- CENTRUM ALSO
CAUSES A NUMBER OF DE
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES BUT
COGNITIVE AND PHYSICAL IN NATURE.
ALTHOUGH THERE IS STILL NO CARE
RESEARCH IS A ME STRIDES IN
DEVELOPING TREATMENTS IT MORE
RESEARCH IS DONE INTO THE
UNDERLYING TODAY GENETIC CAUSES
OF THE DISORDER.
WE MAY FIND IT HERE BUT
UNFORTUNATELY NOT ENOUGH
PRIORITY IS GIVEN TO RESEARCHING
PRADA WILLIE.
WE MUST RAISE MORE AWARENESS ON
THE STATE AND NATIONAL LEVELS
AND FOR THIS DISORDER WE ARE TO
MAKE REAL PROGRESS A NEW GROUND
BREAKING TREATMENTS AS THE L.
AND INTERVENTIONAL CARE.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING
THIS RESOLUTION TO RAISE
AWARENESS FOR PRADA WILLI
SYNDROME I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR WILK MEMBERS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATOR PAN.
HE'S VERY MUCH A MATTER
PRESIDENT CENTERS I TO WANT TO
RISE AND SUPPORTS RESOLUTION AND
THANK MY GOOD FRIEND FROM SANTA
CLARITA FOR BRING THIS.
FOR THIS -- CONDITIONS LIKE
PRADER WILLI ARE ONES THAT --
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
PROGRAMS LIKE CCS TO GENETICALLY
HANDICAPPED PERSONS PROGRAM WE
NEED TO BE SURE WE CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THOSE PROGRAMS ALSO
INVESTING IN BEING SURE THAT.
WE BOTH BE ABLE TO SCREEN BUT
ALSO TO HELP PROVIDE TREATMENTS
FOR THESE FAMILIES -- SO I'M
AGAIN THANK MY GOOD FRIEND FOR
BRINGING THIS RESOLUTION UP AND
APPRECIATE -- HIS ADVOCACY --
FOR PROGRAMS HELP SUPPORT
FAMILIES LIKE THESE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN MEMBERS
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING NONE SIR WHAT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
I WANT TO WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO FOR
THOSE KIND AND ACCURATE WORDS
AND AGAIN ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER WILK MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS.
I BATES.
I BILL [inaudible]
I PORGES.
HI KALLIO.
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD.
HI THE RUSSELL [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
HI GROVE.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
AYE OUR TITLE.
I JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES.
LEYVA HI HI MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING BY MORE LOCK.
I'M REAL.
I NIELSEN.
BY PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
HI ROSS I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
I STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
BY NUMBER.
I WOULD COUNTY I WIENER.
AYE WILK [inaudible]
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
GALGIANI I JONES [inaudible]
BY. FIVE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBER -- SENATOR WELL PLEASE
ENERGY SURE GAS THANK YOU I'M
OUT OF PRESIDENT -- I HAVE THE
EXTREME HONOR OF INTRODUCING
SOME OF THE PEOPLE INVOLVED WITH
THE OF PRODUCT **** CALIFORNIA
FOUNDATION.
WITH ME IS -- MY FRIEND A
CONSTITUENT KAREN KAREN DON WITH
HIS FATHER RODNEY.
HI KAREN LAST YEAR HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LIGHT THE
CHRISTMAS TREE WITH GOVERNOR --
BROWN IN THE FOR AND FIRST LADY
AND GAS BROWN HE DID A FANTASTIC
JOB.
ALSO WITH THIS IS.
HIS TIMOTHY STRONG [inaudible]
RIGHT THERE.
IT HIT AND HIS PARENTS GRAYSON
RICHARD IT FINALLY WITH THIS IS
OF THE PRADA WILLIE CALIFORNIA
FOUNDATION MISTER ROGER KOSHER
SO IF YOU COULD ALL GIVE THEM A
WARM SENATE WELCOME I APPRECIATE.
WHAT
?
THANK YOU CENTER WILK WE ARE
MOVING TO MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WHICH WILL BE DEEMED
READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WHICH
WILL BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEE WHICH WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED
WE'RE NOW MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES
[inaudible]
YEAH.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
FOLLOWING BILLS WITH FOUR
MINUTES WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
FILE ITEM FORTY FOUR SB FOUR OH
TO SENATOR PORCHES.
SENATOR UMBERG FOR PURPOSE YOU
RISE.
UNDER MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
BETTER RESIDENTS PROCEED -- AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
REMOVE ITEM NUMBER SIXTY A. B.
NINE FOUR SIX FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AND MOVE THE BILL TO
THE INACTIVE FILE.
SO NOTED THANK YOU SIR.
SENATOR MITCHELL DID YOU HAVE A
MOTION.
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU FOR
HOLD ME ACCOUNTABLE I APPRECIATE
YOU SO MUCH.
MEMBERS OF THERE'S A LETTER AT
THE DEATH REQUESTING WITHDRAWAL
OF ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY FOUR
FROM THE BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE IN ORDER THE MEASURE
TO SECOND READING I ASKED FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL
CENTER NIELSEN.
NOT A PRESENT ASIA MY **** FOR A
NO VOTE THANK YOU CENTER NIELSEN
MEMBERS SENATOR MITCHELL'S
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE CENTER
NIELSEN IS ASKING.
ABOUT MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI.
ARCHULETA.
BY ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
NOVELL.
I WERE JUST.
BRADFORD.
HI CABALLERO [inaudible]
BY CHIANG [inaudible]
NO DODD.
BY THE RAZA.
AYE GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER AYE GROWTH
[inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
I HILL I WITH SO.
I HER TITLE.
I JACKSON.
BY JONES [inaudible]
NO.
LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE.
HI MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING.
I'M MORE LOCK NO MORALE
[inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH.
AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
I STERN.
AYE STONE.
NO.
NUMBER.
HI MY COUNTY [inaudible]
BY WIENER [inaudible]
HI WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GORGEOUS GROVE NO [inaudible]
WILK. FIVE TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS
EIGHT THE MOTION IS CARE IS
CARRIED.
CYLINDER JONES FOR WHAT PURPOSE
TO RISE.
MADAM PRESIDENT INTRODUCTION
GUESTS INTRODUCTIONS PLEASE
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES IT IS MY
HONOR TODAY.
AND PRIVILEGE TO INTRODUCE
BERLIN DIXON A VERY SUCCESSFUL
YOUNG LADY FROM MY DISTRICT.
WHO IS A FIFTH GRADE STUDENT TO
ADD W. D. HALL ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
IN EL CAJON?
BERLIN HAS BEEN PROMOTED TO THE
PRINCE PRESTIGIOUS HONORARY
POSITION OF COLONEL.
OF THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY SCHOOL
SAFETY PATROLS.
IN AN IN ADDITION TO ENSURING
THE SAFETY OF HER FELLOW
CLASSMATES IN SCHOOL STAFF
BERLIN ALSO LOVES. TO DANCE AND
RUN.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN CONGRATULATING
ASHLEY CASTRO FOR FOR I'M SORRY
FOR BERLIN DIXON FOR PROMOTION
TO COLONEL THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
SAFETY PATROLS BERLIN DIXON UP
IN THE GALLERY.
WELCOME YOUR CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE.
CENTER HER TOTAL FOR PURPOSE TO
RISE. FOR PURPOSES OF
INTRODUCTION.
IT IS MY PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE
TO YOU THE WEST HILLS COLLEGE
THE MORE AG LEADERSHIP CLASS WHO
ARE JOINING US HERE IN THE
GALLERY.
ON THE NORTH SIDE.
PLEASE FOR VETERANS THESE
FOURTEEN STUDENTS HAVE COME FROM
ACROSS THE CENTRAL VALLEY TO
DEVELOP THEIR LEADERSHIP SKILLS
AND RESEARCH SPECIFIC INITIAL
ISSUES IMPACTING CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE.
THE CLASS WILL PRESENT THE
RESULTS OF THE RESEARCH TODAY AT
FOUR PM IN ROOM.
ONE TWENTY SIX OF THE STATE
CAPITOL.
ALSO JOINING THE STUDENTS OF THE
DEAN OF THEIR CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION CHRIS COSTA THE
PROFESSOR DR TONY ALL OF YEAR.
AND INDUSTRY MENTORS MENTORS WHO
HAVE VOLUNTEERED THEIR TIME TO
ASSIST THE BEES FUTURE
AGRICULTURAL LEADERS.
CENTERS PLEASE JOIN ME AND
WALKING THEM TO THE TO THE
SENATE FLOOR.
WELCOME YOUR CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE.
REMOVING THE CONSIDERATION OF
THE DAILY FILE WE WILL START
WITH SECOND READING FILE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SEVEN OH SEVEN THANK
YOU SIR SENATE THIRD READING WE
WILL START WITH FILE ITEM ELEVEN
SENATOR JACKSON'S.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE SIXTY NUMBER
SENATOR JACKSON AND ACT RULING
TO PIPELINE SAFETY SENATE
JACKSON THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES -- I'D LIKE
TO PRESENT SB ONE SIXTY NINE
IT'S A BILL TO ENSURE THAT ALL
INTRASTATE PIPELINES.
THE TRANSPORT OIL ARE PROPERLY
INSPECTED ON AN ANNUAL BASIS.
FOUR YEARS AGO THIS COMING
SUNDAY.
WE SUFFERED AN OIL SPILL THAT
STARTED UP IN REVIEW FEEL BY A
BEAUTIFUL STATE BEACH AND WENT
ALL THE WAY DOWN THE COAST.
WITH HORRIBLE SHOWING UP IN
MANHATTAN BEACH AND OTHER PLACES
THROUGHOUT LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
THE EVENT OCCURRED BECAUSE A
PIPELINE HAD NOT BEEN PROPERLY
MAINTAINED OR INSPECTED.
AND AS A RESULT HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF ECONOMIC
VALUE TO THE COMMUNITY.
WERE DESTROYED TO SAY NOTHING OF
THE WILDLIFE AND THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR PEOPLE TO ENJOY AND WRECKED
CREATE OVER THEN OF MEMORIAL DAY
WEEKEND AT THE BEAUTIFUL BEACHES.
THAT WE HAVE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA SO THIS IS A BILL
THAT STRENGTHENS THE SAFETY
ENFORCEMENT OF THESE PIPELINES
WE DID LEGISLATION TO PROTECT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE WERE DOING
THIS ON AN ANNUAL BASIS BUT
THERE IS A SLIGHT LOOPHOLE.
IN THE LAW.
IF YOU IF YOU ARE ONLY PIPE BUT
A 20% PRESSURE YOU DON'T HAVE TO
MEET THESE REQUIREMENTS WERE
FINDING SOME COMPANIES TRYING TO
AVOID THIS.
RESPONSIBILITY AND THIS IS A
MEASURE THAT'S GOING TO TIGHTEN
IT UP SO THAT ALL THESE
COMPANIES HAVE TO GO THROUGH A
PIPELINE INSPECTION.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION.
ARE WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
INDUSTRY THERE ARE THEY HAVE A
CONCERN ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT
THERE IS A CONFIDENTIALITY -- A
AYE ESPECIALLY IN WITH WITH
RESPECT TO POSITIONING AND TRADE
SECRETS WE ARE WORKING WITH THEM
ON THE FIRE MARSHAL TO COME TO
THE PROPER LANGUAGE -- TO
PROTECT THOSE -- CONCERNS WHICH
ARE LEGITIMATE CONCERNS -- BUT
WE DEFINITELY NEED TO DO THESE
INSPECTIONS AGAIN NO OPPOSITION
WE'VE HAD SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES
AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THE SENATE JACKSON MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING AND
HEARING THEM MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible] FIVE BATES
[inaudible]
BILL.
HI FOR JUST.
BRADFORD.
HI CAMBIADO.
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DOT [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
HI GALGIANI.
I GLAZER AYE GROWTH.
HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
BY HER TITLE [inaudible]
JACKSON.
HI JONES.
NO LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING.
BY MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
MORALE [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
HI PAN [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
PORTANTINO.
HI BY ROB [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
I STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
IOWA CASKEY.
I WINNER.
HI WILK.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
HER TARA [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
STONE.
NIELSEN I DON'T KNOW
[inaudible]
EYES.
THIRTY NOSE TO THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM TWENTY ONE SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE SKI MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THREE OH THREE BY
SENATOR WHY KELSEY AN ACT
RELATING TO GUARDIANS AND
CONSERVATORS CENTER RIGHT
HEALTHY MEN PRESIDENT SENATE
BILL THREE OH THREE INCREASES
PROTECTIONS FOR TWO OF THE
CONSERVANCY'S ESSENTIAL ASSETS.
THE GOVERNMENT BENEFITS AND THE
RESIDENTS THE BILL CLARIFIES
EXISTING LAW PROTECTING A
CONSERVATIVE.
GOVERNMENT BENEFITS FROM BEING
USED TO PAY FOR CONSERVATORS
FEES WITH THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE
TOOK IN COMMITTEE ALL OPPOSITION
AND MY UNDERSTANDING ALL
OPPOSITION HAS BEEN REMOVED AND
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY URGE AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER WHITE HOUSE KEY
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING THEM MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
THINKING HEARING NONE EYES
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MOOD TO FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO
SENATOR DODD MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWO SEVENTY FOUR BY
SENATOR DODD AN ACT RELATING TO
MOBILE HOME RESIDENCY.
CENTER DODD BETTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS.
CALIFORNIA HAS A HOUSING CRISIS
IN MOBILE HOMES ARE ONE OF THE
FEW AVAILABLE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
OPTIONS.
THIS BILL HELPS TO KEEP THIS
SOURCE OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
HELPS KEEP SENIORS AND DISABLED
PEOPLE IN THEIR HOMES.
FIRST OF THIS BILL CLARIFIES
COMPANION LANGUAGE FROM MY TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN SB ONE FORTY
SEVEN ALLOWING FOR UP TO THREE
TOTAL COMPANIONS.
PER CALENDAR YEAR.
SECOND OF A MOBILE HOME PARK IS
DESTROYED BY WILD FIRE RATHER
NATURAL DISASTER THIS BILL WOULD
OFFER PREVIOUS HOMEOWNERS THE
FIRST OFFER TO LIVE IN THE PARK.
IF IT'S REBUILT. THIRTY PROVIDES
CLEARER OF MORE CLEAR FRAMEWORK
FOR WHAT PARK MANAGEMENT SHALL
CONSIDER WHAT APPROVING OR
DENYING A PROSPECTIVE PURCHASER
AND WHAT PERSPECTIVE PURCHASERS
CAN PROVIDE TO PARK MANAGEMENT.
THE GOAL OF THESE CHANGES TO
HELP VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS.
BEAT BECAUSE OF AGE DISABILITY
INCOME OR SOME COMBINATION
THEREOF. FOUR OF WHOM OF FOR
MOBILE HOMES ARE ONE OF THE LAST
VESTIGES OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
I'LL REPEAT WHAT I STATED
COMMITTEE I'M COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION
GOING FORWARD THIS BILL AS WE
SEE BIPARTISAN UNANIMOUS SUPPORT.
IN THE JUSTICE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
THING IN HER RENOWNED MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
NO BELL.
HI PORGES BRADFORD.
HI KELLY AT ALL [inaudible]
HI CHIANG [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
DODD.
HI THE RAZA.
BY GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER BY GROWTH.
NO HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA.
I AM A CHOIR [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MORNING.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORALE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
BY.
PAN.
BY PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY ROTH [inaudible]
ROTH I RUBIO [inaudible]
HI SKINNER [inaudible]
BY STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
NUMBER.
HI WHY COUNTY BY WINNER BY WILK.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
MORE LOCK. FOR LOCKE NO.
ROTH.
I THIRTY ONE KNOWS FIVE THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM TWENTY FOUR
SENATOR CABALLERO MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOR SEVENTY TWO BY
SENATOR CAFIERO AN ACT RELATING
TO FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS.
SENATE CABALLERO THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE TO PRESENT SB
FOUR SEVENTY TWO WHICH PROVIDE
STATUTORY AUTHORITY TO REGULATE
EARNED INCOME ACCESS PROGRAMS.
THESE PROGRAMS ALLOW CONSUMERS
TO ACCESS A PORTION OF THE WAGES
THEY HAVE ALREADY EARNED PRIOR
TO THEIR SCHEDULED PAYDAY FOR A
SINGLE FIXED FEE OFTEN LESS THAN
A TYPICAL BANK.
OVERDRAFT FEE OR A LATE FEE.
WHETHER IT'S THE KEVIN AND NICK
COVER AN UNEXPECTED COST OR JUST
AVOID A LATE FEE SOMETIMES
PEOPLE NEED A LITTLE EXTRA MONEY.
BY CREATING THIS STATUTORY
FRAMEWORK CONSUMERS CAN GET
THEIR MONEY WHEN THEY NEED IT IT
IS A TOOL AND COMES WITH
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS TO ENSURE
THAT THEY ARE HELD HARMLESS.
THERE IS NO DEBT CREATED BECAUSE
A CONSUMER IS ACCESSING THEIR
OWN EARNED ON PAID INCOME.
THEREFORE THERE IS NO DEBT
COLLECTION AND NO LIABILITY IN
THE EVENT OF NON PAYMENT.
THERE IS NO INTEREST CHARGE
THERE IS NO REPORTING OF A NON
PAYMENT TO A CREDIT BUREAU AND A
CONSUMERS CREDIT SCORE IS NOT
THE BASIS FOR PARTICIPATING.
AND SINCE IT'S NOT A LOAN USERS
CANNOT DEFAULT AND THERE IS NO
COMPOUNDING INTEREST.
I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE CONSUMER
PROTECTION GROUPS TO FINE TUNE
THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE WHICH HAS
RECEIVED NO NO VOTES.
AND FINALLY THERE IS FINALLY A
SAFE AND INEXPENSIVE ALTERNATIVE
TO HIGH COST PREDATORY LOANS AND
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER CAP IRO MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING THERE IS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES.
HI BILL.
I PURCHASED BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO.
AYE TING.
AYE DODD [inaudible]
I DORADO.
HI GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
HI -- TADA.
I JACKSON.
I JONES [inaudible]
HI.
LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MORNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
HIGH MORALE [inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
BY PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO.
I ROTH BY RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
STONE.
I AM BURKE.
OUR COUNTY I WINNER.
BY WILK.
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
FOR JUST [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MONEY.
BY CITY FIVE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON THE FILE ITEM
TWENTY SEVEN SENATOR HUESO.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWO AWAY BY SENATOR
WITH AN ACTOR LINDA
COMMUNICATIONS CENTER HUESO
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
I RISE ON THE SENATE FLOOR TO
PRESENT SB TO AWAIT A CONSUMER
PROTECTION BILL AIMED AT
PREVENTING ROBO CALL SCAMS.
ROBO CALL SCAMS FOR THE NUMBER
ONE CONSUMER COMPLAINT IN THE
NATION.
ACCORDING TO THE FEDERAL TRADE
COMMISSION FRAUD GENERATES THE
GREATEST NUMBER OF COMPLAINTS TO
THE COMMISSION AND 70% OF SCAMS
PART OVER THE TELEPHONE.
SPOOFING.
ESPECIALLY NEIGHBOR SPOOFING IS
KEY TO MAKING THESE SCAMS WORK
THE VOLUME OF SPOOFED CALLS IS
INCREASING.
EXPERTS ESTIMATE THE BY 202040%
OF EVERY CALL MADE IN YOUR
TELEPHONE WILL BE A SCAM OR A
SPOOF IN CALL AIMED AT
DEFRAUDING THE CONSUMER.
NEIGHBORHOOD -- NAY THIS BILL
SETS A JULY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
DEADLINE FOR TELECOMMUNICATION
PROVIDERS TO IMPLEMENT CALLER ID
AUTHENTICATION MEMBER MEASURES.
WHICH CAN HELP IDENTIFY THE
LEGAL ROBO CALLS AND PREVENT
CONSUMERS FROM BEING SCAMMED.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES NOT DO?
IT DOES NOT SIGNIFICANT
SIGNIFICANTLY EXPAND THE CPU
SEES AUTHORITY.
IT NARROWLY ALLOWS THE CPUC TO
WORK WITH THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
TO TAKE ACTION AGAINST ILLEGAL
ROBO CALLERS.
IT ALSO DOES NOT REQUIRE CALL
BLOCKING [inaudible]
AND THIS WAS A NUMBER ONE
QUESTION THE COMMITTEE WHETHER
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW CALL
BLOCKING NO IT DOES NOT AND IT
WOULD NOT RESULT.
IN CALLS BEING BLOCKED IT ALSO
DOES NOT CREATE SIGNIFICANT NEW
LIABILITIES FOR TELECOMS ONLY
THOSE THAT DO NOT IMPLEMENT A
CALLER ID.
AUTHENTICATION SYSTEM.
ONLY THOSE THAT DON'T WILL BE IN
VIOLATION WHAT THIS BILL WOULD
DO IT WAS HELL IT WOULD HELP TO
RESTORE CONSUMERS CONFIDENCE IN
USING THEIR PHONES WITHOUT BEING
SCAMS SCAM.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU
CENTER HUESO DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE SENATOR MITCHELL.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I LIKE
THE STANDARD RISING S. IN
SUPPORT.
STAND AND SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
TO AWAIT I THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN DIEGO.
YOU KNOW WE GET CALLS IN OUR
DISTRICT OFFICES.
AND I CONVENE A SENIOR DISCOUNT
OF IT EVERY DAY IN THE DISTRICT
AND WE MOVED AROUND THE DISTRICT
AND I AM STRUCK.
BY THE NUMBER OF SENIORS WHO
WILL COME TO THE VAN.
OUT OF FEAR AND SHAME THEY DON'T
WITH THEIR ADULT CHILDREN TO NOW --
THAT THEY HAVE BEEN SUBJECT TO A
SCAM.
AND SO WE TALK ABOUT THE CONTEXT
OF SINGERS ALL THE TIME.
AND WHILE I'M NOT YET OFFICIALLY
JOINED.
THAT [inaudible]
A DEMOGRAPHIC.
I TO GOT A CALL ON MY CELL PHONE
LAST WEEK -- A ROBO CALL.
OUR AND WE'VE HEARD IN THE NEWS
ABOUT YOU KNOW THE IRS AND SO I
THINK THAT THAT'S PER MEETING
PEOPLE KNOW THE IRS WILL CALL
YOU THE LOVE BUT THIS ONE WAS
SUPPOSEDLY FROM SOCIAL SECURITY.
AND I WAS TOLD THAT THERE WAS A
FRAUD CLAIM AGAINST MY SOUL
SECURITY CARD AND CALL BACK
RIGHT AWAY.
SO I GOT THE CALL 234- TIMES IN
THE FIFTH TIME I WAS LITERALLY
IN THE BASEMENT AND I ANSWER THE
HAPPEN CATCH THEM.
AND SO THE MOMENT I AND OF
COURSE SHE ASKED ME FOR MY SOUL
SECURITY NUMBER.
AND SO TO THINK.
THAT CLEARLY IT'S WORKING ARE
THEY WOULDN'T CONTINUE TO INVEST
THE RESOURCES THEY ARE.
THE WROBEL CALLED NUMBER THAT
CAME UP ON MY PHONE SAID SO
SECURITY IT DIDN'T SAY SO SECURE
WITH MINISTRATION SO THE LINKS
THAT THAT PEOPLE ARE GOING
THROUGH. TO SCAM RESIDENTS IT'S
JUST.
TRAGIC AND SO AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
MY CONSTITUENTS THE HORROR
STORIES I'VE HEARD IS BEING
ELECTED I WANT TO SUPPORT THIS
EFFORT AND AND MANY MORE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE PROTECT PRIVACY IN
THE RIGHTS.
OF INDIVIDUAL RESIDENTS OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ST IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO AWAY.
THANK YOU CENTER MITCHELL
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING AND HEARING THE ANSWER
WAS WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
JUST LIKE TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FOR SHARING THAT PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE.
AND ALSO -- TRIED IN OUR
ARTICULATE THAT OTHER THESE
CALLS ARE GETTING CHEAPER AND
CHEAPER TO MAKE.
SO MORE PEOPLE ARE MAKING THEM
ILLEGALLY.
AND IT'S IT'S IT'S COSTING OF
INNOCENT PEOPLE LOTS OF MONEY.
BUT THE IDEA IS THE MORE CALLS
THEY MAKE THE MORE INVOLVED YOU
ARE ARE ARE GENERATED THROUGHOUT.
OUR STATE IN OUR OUR COMMUNITY
THAT THEY'LL EVENTUALLY CATCH
SOMEBODY THAT WILL WILL FALL
PREY TO THEIR SCHEME.
AND THAT'S HOW THEY SUCCEED AND
THIS.
IT'S IT'S VERY IMPORTANT WE DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO LIMIT THEIR
SUCCESS AND TO ELIMINATE THIS
FROM HAPPENING -- TO
UNSUSPECTING CONSUMERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FREE AYE VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
HUESO MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
BY BILL.
BY BURGESS.
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
BY CHIANG [inaudible]
BY DOT [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
BY GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROVE [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO.
HI -- TADO.
BY JACKSON BY JONES [inaudible]
BY.
LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE [inaudible]
HI MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONEY.
BY MID JULY MORE LOCK
[inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO PAN.
HI PORTANTINO AYE ROTH.
AYE RUBIO.
I SKINNER AYE STERN.
AYE STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
HI WHAT COUNTY.
HI WINNER.
BY WILK.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
REGIS.
BRADFORD BY [inaudible]
HI ROBI [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
MORE LUCK.
GROVE NO MORE LOCK NO.
I IS THIRTY TWO KNOWS FIVE THE
MEASURE PASSES -- TO FILE ITEM
TWENTY NINE SENATOR UMBERG
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THREE HUNDRED BY
SENATOR UMBERG ENACT GOING TO
THE POLITICAL FORM ACT OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR CENTER I'M
BURKE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES THE POLITICAL REFORM
ACT CURRENTLY PROHIBITS.
FOREIGN PERSONS AND
ORGANIZATIONS FOR MAKING
CONTRIBUTIONS OR DEPEND
EXPENDITURES A. CONNECTION WITH
STATE LOCAL BALLOT MEASURE
CAMPAIGNS SB THREE HUNDRED WILL
AMEND THE P. ARRAY. TO ALSO
PREFER THIS ACTIVITY IN
CONNECTION WITH CALIFORNIA'S
LOCAL CANDIDATE CAMPAIGNS ARJUN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR UMBERG.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING
AND HEARING THAT MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
AYE BILL.
I PORGES.
BRADFORD.
HI CABALLERO.
I CHIANG.
I DODD.
HI THERE ALSO.
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
HI.
I HILL AYE HUESO AYE ARE TADO.
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES.
LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE [inaudible]
HI MITCHELL [inaudible]
HI MONNING [inaudible]
HI.
MORE LUCK.
I'M REAL [inaudible]
I NIELSEN.
I PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH [inaudible]
HI RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER I STERN AYE STONE.
AYE HAMBURG I WOULD COUNTY AYE
WIENER.
AYE WILK.
HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
JONES.
I THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM. THIRTY FIVE SENATOR
CABALLERO MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE FIFTEEN BY
SENATOR CAFIERO AN ACT RELATED
TO ENERGY.
THIRD CABALLERO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES IN THE PAST FEW YEARS
CALIFORNIA HAS THAT HAD HAD HAS
HAD.
SOME OF THE MOST DEADLY AND
COSTLY FIRES IN THE STATE'S
HISTORY AND CLIMATE EXPERTS
AGREE THAT WE CAN EXPECT MORE
DEVASTATING.
AND EXTREME WHILE FLYER FLOWER
HIKERS.
AND DROUGHT SOME HAVING A HARD
TIME TODAY WHICH CONTRIBUTE TO
FLORIDA FOR ITS DIE OFF.
THAT IS WHY I AM PLEASED TO RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT SB FIVE ONE
FIVE HE NARROWLY FOCUSED BILL
THAT WOULD EXPAND THE DEFINITION
OF HIGH HAZARD FUEL FOR BIOMASS
FACILITIES.
WITH BIO RAM CONTRACTS BIOMASS
IS THE USE OF ANY ORGANIC
MATERIAL INCLUDING FOREST
THINNING AGRICULTURAL UP CROPS
URBAN WOULD WASTE TO GENERATE
HEATING COOLING ELECTRICITY OR
FUELS.
IT KEEPS OUR FORESTS HEALTHY AND
PUT PUTS BY PRODUCTS LIKE
TRIMMINGS SAWMILL RESIDUE AN
AGRICULTURAL RESIDUE TO GOOD USE.
GIVEN ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S FOREST
MANAGEMENT CHALLENGES INCLUDING
WILDFIRES PASSED INFANT
INFESTATION LIKE BARK BEETLE AND
THE HUNDRED AND FORTY SEVEN
MILLION DEAD AND DYING TREES.
ENSURING THAT CONTRACTED BIOMASS
FACILITIES CONTINUE TO TAKE ON
AS MUCH HIGH PRIORITY MATERIAL
MAKES SENSE.
SB FIVE ONE FIVE EXPAND THE
DEFINITION OF HIGH HAZARD.
ZONE FUEL TO INCLUDE THE AREAS
WITHIN A WILDFIRE SINCE. TWELVE
TWENTY TWELVE WHICH IS
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT CAL FIRE
ANNOUNCED EARLIER IN THE YEAR.
AS WELL AS EXPAND IT TO INCLUDE
HEALTH FIRES MAPS WHICH SHOW
THESE HAZARDS OWNS.
RATHER THAN WAIT UNTIL A
DEVASTATING WILDFIRE DESTROYS A
COMMUNITY BEFORE REMOVING THE
FUEL WE SHOULD GET OUT IN FRONT
OF SOME OF THESE ISSUES AND TRY
TO PREVENT THE NEXT MAJOR
WILDFIRE.
THIS BILL IS A SMALL BUT
IMPORTANT STEP TO IMPROVE THE
CONDITIONS IN OUR FOREST AND
HELP PROTECT COMMUNITIES FROM
WILDFIRES WHERE THERE IS EXCESS
FUEL I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
BUT YOU CENTER CABALLERO
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE SENATOR
NIELSEN.
MADAM PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN OF THE SENATE I THANK
THE AUTHOR OF THIS LEGISLATION.
LONG LONG OVERDUE. FOR DECADES
STATE AND FEDERAL POLICY.
HAVE LOCKED UP.
THE FOREST IN THE WILD LANDS.
ALLOWING NO THINNING.
NO REAL MANAGE.
OF THOSE IMMENSE GROSS.
PARTICULAR THE UNDERBRUSH.
THE CAUSATIVE FACTORS IN THESE
MASSIVE AND INCREASINGLY
DISASTROUS [inaudible]
WILDFIRES.
THESE POLICIES HAVE CONTRIBUTED.
TO THE MYERS AND CO GENERATION.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
THE MILLS.
THAT WOULD PROCESS LOGS.
THEY'RE MOSTLY GONE.
THE JOBS ALONG WITH IT.
AND THE SAFETY.
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN.
ENHANCED [inaudible]
BY REMOVAL.
OF MANY TREES.
AND VERY PARTICULARLY.
ALL OF THIS BY -- MAX.
THAT HAS CONTRIBUTED AND BEEN
THE MAJOR CONTRIBUTING FACTOR.
TO THESE MASSIVE FIRES
[inaudible]
THIS LEGISLATION.
WILL BE HELPFUL.
IN STATING STATE POLICY.
AND ENCOURAGING INVEST ORDERS.
THE BUILD COGENERATION PLANTS
[inaudible]
THE PROCESS.
THESE EXCESSIVE ACCUMULATIONS
[inaudible]
OF FUELS.
I SPEAK WITH THE PASSION ABOUT
THIS.
HAVING REPRESENTED NINETEEN
COUNTIES IN ALL OF THE ATTENDED
FIRES OF THE FLICK TO THOSE MANY
COUNTIES.
OF ALL SORTS.
AND LAST YEAR AN ENTIRE TOWN
[inaudible]
DESTROY.
BY SUCH FIRES [inaudible]
I URGE.
THE SAFETY OF OUR CONSTITUENTS.
AND THE ECONOMY OF CALIFORNIA.
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER NIELSEN.
THING -- FURTHERS THIS QUESTION
OR DEBATE TO RECOVER WHICH I TO
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY THEY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE I THIRTY
SEVEN KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE BACK IN THE FILE THEIR
ORDER TO FILE ITEM.
THIRTY TWO CENTER GLAZER YOU
PREPARED MR SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL THREE NINETY
SEVEN BY SENATOR GLAZER AN ACT
RELATING TO TRANSIT OPERATORS.
CENTER GLAZER THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS.
THIS LEGISLATION BEFORE YOU
WOULD REQUIRE PUBLIC TRANSIT
OPERATORS. TO ALLOW PASSENGERS
TO BOARD A TRANSIT VEHICLE WITH
THEIR PETS.
WHEN AN EVACUATION ORDER HAS
BEEN ISSUED?
WOULD ALSO REQUIRE EACH PUBLIC
TRANSIT OPERATOR TO DEVELOP BEST
PRACTICES FOR ALLOWING PETS ON
PUBLIC TRANSIT VEHICLES IN AN
EVACUATION SITUATION.
BILLS RECEIVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
NO NO VOTES AND I WOULD ASK FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION TODAY.
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER MEMBERS
THIS SENATOR DODD. THIRTY SEVEN
GLAZER WHERE YOU TAKE A QUESTION.
YES PLEASE PROCEED SENATOR DODD
TO THE GOOD THAT SENATOR FROM
AROUND I'M WONDERING IF THIS
WOULD INCLUDE.
TRANSIT VEHICLES ARE A THOMAS
VEHICLES.
WELL WILL FOLLOW THE LAW AS
PRESCRIBED BY THE GREAT -- BODY
HERE IN THE SENATE AND THE
ASSEMBLY IN OUR GOVERNOR SO
WHATEVER IS ALLOWED UNDER THE
CURRENT LAW WE WOULD -- WE WOULD
APPLY THAT TO THE EVACUATION OF
OUR WONDERFUL LOVELY PAT SO --
HOPEFULLY IN A SAFE MANNER WITH --
ALL THE ASSISTANCE THAT IT
REQUIRES.
THANK YOU SEE NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CENTER
CLOSE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTES THANK YOU SIR MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM THIRTY
SIX SENATOR STERN ARE YOU READY
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE TWENTY FOUR BY
SENATOR STERN AND ACT REALLY AND
ENERGY.
SENATOR STERN.
PAYMENT OF PRESIDENT MEMBERS SB
FIVE TWENTY FOUR PROMOTES
CALIFORNIA'S ENERGY EFFICIENCY
AND GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
GOALS.
BUT PROTECTING REPAIR FUNDS
ENSURING THAT WE'RE GETTING HIGH
QUALITY WORK OUT THERE FOR
LARGER ENERGY EFFICIENCY
MEASURES.
RIGHT NOW THE COMPLIANCE RATE
FOR OUR BUILDING CODES ARE
SIMPLY NOT BEING MET WE PASS
AMBITIOUS CODES BUT THE QUALITY
OF THE JOBS OUT THERE FOR LARGER
PROJECTS TO THE COMMERCIAL SCALE
JUST AREN'T DELIVERING.
AS LITTLE AS 51% OF EXPECTED
SAVINGS IN FACT ACCORDING TO
RECENT STUDIES.
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION IS
REPORTED THE MORE THAN 85% OF
RESIDENTIAL REPLACEMENT.
H. BACK SYSTEMS AND MORE THAN
50% IN NEW CONSTRUCTION OR
INSTALL THEIR DESIGNED
INCORRECTLY IS A PROBLEM THAT I
THINK WE NEED TO FIX I'LL BE AT
THE RATE PAYERS AND OUR
ENVIRONMENT AND OUR WORKERS AND
WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I
THINK YOU SOONER STERN MEMBERS
DISCUSSION.
OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
I URSULA.
I ATKINS AYE BATES.
BILL.
BY PORGES.
BRADFORD.
BY CABALLERO.
I CHIANG [inaudible]
BY DOT.
BY THE RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER [inaudible]
GROWTH.
NO [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
I JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE.
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONNING.
I'M MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH [inaudible]
BY RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER.
ISTERN.
AYE STONE.
NO.
NUMBER.
IOWA COUNTY.
I WIENER AYE WILK.
BY.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
HI.
ICE THIRTY NO SEVEN THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING ON
THE FILE ITEM FORTY ONE SENATOR
BRADFORD MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
THIRTY ONE BEST RAPPER.
THANK MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
PROCEED CENTER BRADFORD THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND I'M HERE
TO PRESENT AS C. R. THIRTY ONE
WHICH RECOGNIZES AND HONORS
WILLIE.
LEWIS BROWN JUNIOR BY NAMING THE
PUBLIC STREET CIRCLE IN PLAZA
NINE FOURTEEN AND NINE FIFTEEN
CAPITAL MALL AS WILLIE L. BROWN
JUNIOR CIRCLE AND PLAZA.
MISTER BROWN IS WIDELY REGARDED
AS ONE OF THE MOST.
INFLUENTIAL POLITICIANS OF THE
LATE TWENTIETH CENTURY.
AND HAS BEEN AT THE CENTER OF
CALIFORNIA'S GOVERNMENT AND
CIVIC LIFE FOREIGN STANDING
SOUNDING FOR DECADES IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY MISTER BROWN MADE HISTORY
BY BECOMING THE FIRST.
AFRICAN AMERICAN SPEAKER HERE IN
THE CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY.
A POSITION HE HELD FOR FIFTEEN
YEARS AND ON THE CURRENT TERM
LIMITS WILL NEVER BE SURPASSED.
DURING HIS THIRTY YEAR TENURE AS
AN ELECTED MEMBER OF THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY MISTER BROWN.
LEFT HIS IMPRINT ON EVERY ASPECT
A PUBLIC POLICY IMPACT IN THE
GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA
SPECIFICALLY HIS LEADERSHIP
RESULTED IN LEGISLATION THAT
BANNED SEMI AUTOMATIC WEAPONS.
GAINES STATE THAT VESTED JUROR
IN SOUTH AFRICA IN CREATED
STABILITY AND EDUCATION SYSTEM
TO SCHOOL FINANCE REFORM
FOLLOWING HIS MONUMENTAL ROLE AS
SPEAKER OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSEMBLY.
MISTER BROWN CONTINUED HIS
GROUND BREAKING CAREER BY BEING
ELECTED THE FIRST AFTERNOON
AMERICAN MAYOR OF THE CITY OF
SAN FRANCISCO WHERE HE SERVED
TWO TERMS.
AS MAYOR OF AS MAYOR MR BROWN
REFURBISHED AND AND REBUILD
CALIFORNIA'S BUSIEST TRANSIT
SYSTEM PART NEAR TO USE A BOND
MEASURES TO BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
AND CREATED A MODEL JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM THESE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS ARE JUST A BRIEF
GLIMPSE OF THE VARIETY OF
FORWARD THINKING POLICY IDEAS --
THAT HAVE BEEN FULLY REALIZED
UNDER MISTER BROWN'S LEADERSHIP
AS YOUR THIRTY ONE CELEBRATE
CELS ACCOMPLISHMENTS AS WELL AS
MISTER BROWN'S UNRELATED
RELENTING DEDICATION TO A BETTER
CALIFORNIA I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER BRADFORD
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE CENTER
NIELSEN.
THAT ARE PRESENT LAYS DOWN WITH
THE SENATE I RISE IN SUPPORT.
OF THIS MEASURE.
NOW IT COULD BE CLAIMED IT WOULD
NOT GET ME MANY VOTES IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
BUT I DISAGREE AND I THINK MY
REPUTATION IS SUFFICIENT THAT I
DON'T WORRY ABOUT THAT.
I SERVED FIVE YEARS IN THIS.
BUILDING IN THIS HOUSE.
AS REPUBLICAN LEADERS.
DEALING WITH WILLIE BROWN THE
SPEAKER OF THE ASSEMBLY.
THE ALL POWERFUL SPEAKER BROWN.
AND A COUPLE OF EXAMPLES.
SOME UP OUR RELATIONSHIP.
WE WERE SITTING TOGETHER AT
ARNOLD'S FIRST INAUGURATION
[inaudible]
CHECK CHECK.
THEN I SAID WILLING I'M A
REPUBLICAN WHO SING YOUR PRAISES
OUT ON THE HUSTINGS FREQUENTLY.
NOW WE ALWAYS CALL ME JAMES
JAMES WHY WOULD YOU SAY THAT
GOOD ABOUT WILLIE BROWN THAT
JUST GET YOU IN TROUBLE.
I SAID REALLY WHAT I SAY.
THIS WAS A TWO IF YOU MADE A
DEAL WITH ME.
YOU KEPT YOUR WORD AND YOU
DELIVERED THE BOAT.
SAID YOU DELIVER THE VOTES JIM.
I SAID THAT'S WHAT I MEAN
WILLING [inaudible]
YOUR PERSON.
WHO KEPT THE WART?
IF YOU LOSE IT LATER WHERE AGAIN
TOGETHER.
IS IT JAMES WHY IS IT WHEN YOU
PUNCH ME IN THE NOSE I'M SMILING.
I SAID WELL REALLY THE SAME
REASON WHENYOU PUNCH ME IN THE
NOSE I SMILE.
WE DO IT RESPECTFULLY FACTUALLY
AND WE DO NOT TAKE IT
[inaudible]
PERSONALLY.
IT WAS A DYNAMIC HE IS A DYNAMIC
MAN I STILL ENJOYS CALL
[inaudible]
HE WAS.
A GOOD LEGISLATIVE LEADERS. ONE
OF THE BEST.
AND HE DID KEEP HIS WORD.
ARJUN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER NIELSEN SENATOR
PM.
THANK YOU A MATTER PRESENT
SENATORS LIKE TO RISE AND
SUPPORT AND AS SINCE THIS --
STREET IS ACTUALLY IN MY
DISTRICT.
I APPRECIATE THE LEADERSHIP
CERTAINLY -- THAT -- SPEAKER
BROWN -- SPEAKER MAYOR WHATEVER
BROWN HAD HERE IN CERTAIN OUR
LEGISLATURE AND I THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE TO COMMEMORATE HIM
IN THIS WAY -- NEAR OUR STATE
BUILDINGS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHEN I THAT.
THANK YOU CENTER PAN CENTER
BRADFORD WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
CENTER I'M BURGER APOLOGIZE I
DID NOT SEE YOUR MICROPHONE
PLEASE PROCEED -- THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES -- I
SERVE WILLIE BROWN -- WILLIE
BROWN WAS AND IS A FRIEND OF
MINE.
STORIES OF WILLIE BROWN AND HIS
LEADERSHIP ARE LEGION HE WAS
PERHAPS THE SMARTEST LEGISLATORS
EVER SERVE IN THIS BUILDING --
BUT ONE OF MY FAVORITE STORIES
IS THAT WILLIE WAS THE
CONSUMMATE POLITICIAN AND AS WAS
POINTED OUT HE WAS SPEAKER
LONGER THAN ANYONE HAD BEEN OR
EVER WILL BE SPEAKER.
AND COMING FROM ORANGE COUNTY
WHERE WILLIE BROWN WAS A
CONVERSE SO FIGURE.
AND HE SAID THE AS I WAS RUNNING
FOR REELECTION SAID I WANT TO
SUPPORT YOU IN ANY WAY I CAN.
I WILL ENDORSE YOUR DENOUNCE YOU
WHICH EVER GETS YOU MORE VOTE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SAID I WORK
AND I VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR -- CENTER WIENER.
I THANK YOU -- SOMEONE WHO
REPRESENTS -- THE AREA -- THAT --
REALLY BROWN USED TO REPRESENT
IN THE ASSEMBLY -- AND WHO --
CALLED HIM -- MY MAYOR -- FOR
THOSE EIGHT YEARS OF THE SERVER
I SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS -- OF
THIS LEGISLATION -- WILLIE BROWN
IS -- WHETHER PEOPLE WERE
ALIGNED AND ALIGNED WITH THEM --
ONE OF THE ABSOLUTE MOST
BRILLIANT POLITICAL MINDS -- IN
MODERN HISTORY AND HE IS THERE
WILL NEVER BE ANOTHER WILLIE
BROWN AND I RESTORE CLASS WHEN I
GO.
THANK YOU CENTER WIENER SENATOR
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
LOUIS BROWN.
WAS FROM MINEOLA TEXAS.
AND HE IS OFTEN KNOWN FOR HIS
EXTRAORDINARY HUMOR AND HIS
INTELLECT THAT WAS EXPRESSED ON
THE FLOOR TODAY.
HIS LONGEVITY ABILITY.
TO OPERATE THE POLITICAL SYSTEM
AN ELEGANT WAY.
BUT I RISE BECAUSE HE WAS A
FELLOW.
WHO NEVER LOST HIS WAY WHO
UNDERSTOOD HIS ROOTS WHEN HE
STOOD ON THE FLOOR TALKING ABOUT
CIVIL RIGHTS OR ABOUT THE
DOWNTRODDEN ABOUT EDUCATION HE
SPOKE WITH GREAT COMPASSION
WITHOUT NOTES ABOUT WHO WE WAS
AND WHAT HE WAS ABOUT?
AND THE OIL IS THE OIL IS AS WE
LOOK AT PEOPLE OR POWERFUL AND
ALL THESE THINGS TO ME.
IT'S ABOUT YOUR COR YOUR MORAL
CORE AND DID HE MAKE A LOT OF
DEALS NO QUESTION ABOUT IT DID
HE STAY IN POWER AN
EXTRAORDINARY TIME NO DOUBT
ABOUT IT.
BUT HE NEVER LOST HIS PASSION
HIS CORE ABOUT THE VALUES OF
WHAT WHAT INFORMED HIM EVER ONCE
AND I RISES FOR THIS MAJOR.
THANK YOU CENTER HERTZBERG
SENATOR MITCHELL.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AFTER
THAT I FELT COMPELLED TO STAND
IN RISE TO REMIND US ALL THAT --
WE LOSE BROWN IS INDEED STILL
AMONG THE LIVING.
I DO STAND IN SUPPORT OF F. C.
R..
THIRTY ONE IT'S IMPORTANT WE
GIVE PEOPLE THEIR FLOWERS WHILE
THEY'RE ABOVE GROUND SO I'M SURE
HE'S MONITORING TODAY'S
PROCEEDINGS.
HE WILL OF MONITORED HEARD ALL
THE NICE THINGS EVERYONE SAID
ABOUT IN BUT I JUST FELT
COMPELLED TO SAY HE'S STILL HERE
WERE SIMPLY NAME IN A COURT IN
HIS HONOR.
I STAND IN SUPPORT OF THAT C. R..
THIRTY ONE THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL.
SEE NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE CENTER BREVARD'S LIKE TO
CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I WANT
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES WHO'VE
WEIGHTY AND TO JUST GIVE A
GLIMPSE OF WILLIE LOUIS BROWN.
IS AND STILL VERY MUCH AMONGST
US -- IT IS ALWAYS A GREAT.
THE LIGHT FOR ME JUSTICE MAN ANY
TIME IN ITS TO RELIGION IS
COMPANY AND I'VE ALSO OFTEN
ASKING WHAT WAS THE KEY TO ITS
SUCCESS.
AND DESPITE BEING A STAUNCH
DEMOCRAT IT WAS NEVER ABOUT
PARTY WAS ABOUT RELATIONSHIPS IS
ABOUT KNOWING HIS COLLEAGUES WHO
WAS ABOUT INTEGRITY.
AND THAT'S WHAT BEST EXEMPLIFIES
MISTER BROWN.
AND BILL THIS IS A SMALL CIRCLE
IN A PLAZA HE'S VERY MUCH WORK.
NAME EMAIL ST WILLIE L. BROWN L.
STREET AFTER HIM BUT WE'RE GOING
TO SETTLE FOR THIS PLAZA HE IS
RIGHT -- REPUTATION PRECEDES HIM
AND I THINK OF ALL THE
COLLEAGUES WHO'S WHO HAVE SERVED
WITH HIM AND KNOWN OVER THE
YEARS AND THOSE WHO HAVE HAD
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET UP.
WITH -- IT GREEN HE'S A FINE
EXAMPLE WHAT PUBLIC SERVICE IS
ALL ABOUT WHAT A PUBLIC SERVANT.
IS ABOUT AND WHAT INTEGRITY IN
LEADERSHIP BEST REPRESENT SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR BRADFORD
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE EYES
THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FORTY TWO
SEVEN REQUIRE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE SIXTY BY
SENATOR REQUIRE AN ACT RELATING
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT CENTER
MCGUIRE.
HAD A MONDAY THAT A PRESIDENT
THANK YOU SO MUCH THE WAY SOME
ACT PROTECTS FROM DEVELOPMENT
APPROXIMATELY FIFTEEN POINT TWO
MILLION ACRES OF LAND IN FIFTY
TWO CALIFORNIA COUNTIES.
OVER TIME THE PROGRAM IS CHANGE
BASED ON FEEDBACK FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS. ONE SUCH YOU'RE A
REGARDS TO REMAIN WHICH
BEGINNING IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN MUST BE INCLUDED IN A TEN
MILLION PROTECTION ZONE INSTEAD
OF THE WHIMS IN ACTING ORDER
RECEIVE PROPERTY TAX BENEFITS.
SB FIVE SIXTY REPEALS AN
OUTDATED PROVISION IN STATE LAW
THAT PROVIDES THAT LAND ZONE IS
SIMILAR PRODUCTION.
COUNTED TOWARDS ONE ACRE MINIMUM
SIZE FOR IN AGRICULTURE PRESERVE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY ABOUT
MENOPAUSE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MCGUIRE
MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE EYES
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING ON THE FILE ITEM
FORTY THREE SENATOR MORALE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 6406% OF MORAL AN
ACT RELATING TO UTILITY SERVICES
SENATOR MORALE YES THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS -- TODAY
I PRESENT SB.
SIX FORTY SIX SB SIX FORTY SIX
CONTINUES A POLICY THAT IS
WIDELY AGREED UPON.
IN IS IN THE SAME SPIRIT OF THE
LANDMARK CALIFORNIA LAWS AND
LACK AND ENACTED BY OUR VOTERS
IN PROPOSITIONS -- TO EIGHTEEN
NUMBER TWENTY SIX THE POLICY WE
ALL GENERALLY AGREE ON IS THAT
WHEN A LOCAL GOVERNMENT CHARGES
FEES A SHOULD BE FAIR AND
REASONABLE AND YOU SOLELY FOR
THE PURPOSES WHICH THEY ARE
CHARGED.
SB SIX FORTY SIX MAKES ONE
SIMPLE CLARIFICATION TO THE
MITIGATION FEE ACT AND THAT'S TO
MAKE THE POLICY ABUNDANTLY CLEAR.
THIS IS A BIPARTISAN BILL AND
WITH NOT A SINGLE NO VOTE.
AND SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR RIVAL TODAY -- TO HELP
CLARIFY THE LAW THANK YOU.
THE SOONER MORRELL MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE EYES
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING TO FILE ITEM FORTY
SIX SENATOR PAN MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE FORTY THREE BY
SENATOR PAN AN ACRYLATE VEHICLES.
CENTER PAN THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SENATORS AND TWENTY
FIFTEEN THIS LEGISLATURE
UNANIMOUSLY PASSED SB FIVE
THIRTY A BILL I INTRODUCED.
ESTABLISHES A UNIFORM SET OF
SAFETY SPECIFICATIONS OPERATE
HELLO POWER CORD TO CYCLES IN
CALIFORNIA SOMETIMES KNOWN AS
PURE BIKES.
ARE PEDICABS.
CORD TO CYCLES ARE MULTI
PASSENGER BICYCLES THAT
PRIMARILY RELY ON HUMAN POWER
FROM THE MEN NUMBER DRIVEN BY
INDIVIDUALS WHO.
ARE DRIVEN BY INDIVIDUALS NOT
PEDAL -- THIS LAW REQUIRES --
THESE FIVE CYCLES FOLLOW STATE
REGULATIONS IF ALCOHOL BEVERAGES
OR CONSUME THE QUADRICYCLE
EXISTING LAW ALSO REQUIRES THAT
MUST BE AUTHORIZED BY LOCAL
ORDINANCES.
THIS LAW IS DUE TO SUNSET AND
JERRY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY AND SB
FIVE FORTY THREE THOUGHT SEEKS
TO THE LEAD TO SUNSET DATE TO
THESE INNOVATIVE SMALL
BUSINESSES CAN CONTINUE TO
FORESTALL OPERATE SAFELY ON CITY
STREETS.
THE BILL HAS RECEIVED NO NO
VOTES NOR OPPOSITION HAS TO
SUPPORT A SECOND A POLICE
DEPARTMENT EXPECT THE ASPIRIN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN MEMBERS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING THEM NICE
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MVING TO FILE ITEM.
FORTY EIGHT EXCUSE ME BALLOT IN.
FORTY SEVEN SENATOR ALLEN MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SIX FORTY ONE BY
SENATOR ALLEN AND ACTUALLY TO
ELECTIONS SENATOR ALLEN.
WITH SO MUCH A MATTER PRESENT
MEMBERS SB SIX FORTY ONE WILL
EXTEND THE TIMELINE FOR SPECIAL
ACTION CONSOLIDATION FROM ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY TO TWO HUNDRED
DAYS.
FOLLOWING THE ELECTION
PROCLAMATION AND WE'RE ALL A
FAMILIAR WITH THE INCREASE IN
SPECIAL ELECTIONS AS OCCURRED
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL DECADES IN
THIS BILL.
GIVES THE GOVERNOR MORE
FLEXIBILITY TO WORK WITH LOCAL
COUNTIES DETERMINE THE BEST
STATE. FOR SPECIAL ELECTIONS BY
GIVING LOCAL JURISDICTIONS A A
LONGER TIME LINE TO CONSOLIDATE
THE SPECIAL ELECTION.
THE BILL MAY INCREASE THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT A SPECIAL ACTION
COULD BE THEN CONDUCTED
SIMULTANEOUSLY WITH THE REGULAR
SCHEDULED ELECTION IN A
JURISDICTION.
WHICH WOULD RESULT IN INCREASED
VOTER TURNOUT COST SAVINGS THIS
CAME BECAUSE OF APPEAR TO TIME
IN SENATOR AND CENTER FROM
DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES IS DISTRICT --
CENTER -- SO WHERE WHERE THEY
HAD ABOUT THE ABOUT FOR SPECIAL
ELECTIONS IN THE COURSE OF THREE
MONTHS -- THEY JUST CAN GET
RIDICULOUS LET'S FIGURE OUT A
WAY TO GIVE THE GOVERNOR A
LITTLE MORE FLEXIBILITY AND I
SAID YES AND I HAVE A THANK YOU
CENTER ELLEN.
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE FIVE
THREE SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
NOW WE'LL MOVE ON THE FILE ITEM.
FORTY EIGHT SENATOR STERN.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FORTY THREE BY SENATOR STERN
RELATIVE TO THANK THOSE
AWARENESS WEEK.
SENATOR IR MY APOLOGIES MADAME
PRESIDENT NOT A PROBLEM THANK
YOU -- MEMBERS I RISE TO
DESIGNATE MAY FIFTH THROUGH MAY
ELEVENTH AS COMPOST AWARENESS
WEEK THANK YOU TO ALL THE
MEMBERS WHO SUPPORT THIS
AWARENESS -- AND OTHERS WHO MAY
BE IMPACTED BY ORGANIC MATERIALS
MAKE UP 30% OF THE TEARS GOING
TO LANDFILLS.
AND IT'S A VERY EFFECTIVE FOR
WASTE REDUCTION SO AS GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION.
pTHE SOIL ALSO IMPROVES WATER
QUALITY AND INCREASE OUR
DEPENDENCE ON CHEMICAL
FERTILIZERS AND HARMFUL
PESTICIDES.
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR JOINING E
THIS WEEK.
IN RECOGNIZING INTERNATIONAL
COMPOSTING AWARENESS WEEK.
PLEASE ENTER STERN MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED MOVING ON
THE FILE ITEM FORTY NINE SENATOR
DODD MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FORTY FOUR BY SENATOR DODD
RELATIVE TO PRIVACY AWARENESS
WEEK SENATOR DODD.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS S. C. R. FORTY FOUR WITH
DECLARE THE THIRD WEEK OF MAY AS
PRIVACY AWARENESS WEEK.
CALIFORNIA WAS THE FIRST STATE
TO REQUIRE NOTIFICATION OF
PERSONAL INFORMATION EXPOSED AS
A RESULT OF A DATA BREACH.
AND THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMER
PRIVACY ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN ESTABLISHED NATION
LEADING PRIVACY RIGHTS FOR
CONSUMERS.
THIS RESOLUTION HELPS INCREASE
AWARENESS OF RISKS THE CONSUMERS
PRIVACY AND THE STEPS THEY CAN
TAKE TO PROTECT PRIVATE
INFORMATION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD MEMBERS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO USE UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE EYES
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FIFTY TWO
SENATOR RUBIO.
PASS ON FOR MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION THIRTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR RUBIO RELATIVE TO THE
DAY OF THE TEACHER.
SENATOR RUBIO THANK YOU THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT A MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE. TO INTRODUCE THIS
WOMAN'S CAUCUS RESOLUTION THAT
DECLARES MAY EIGHT TWENTY
NINETEEN OUR STATE OF THE
TEACHER.
THIS RESOLUTION URGES ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO OBSERVE THE DAY
THE TEACHER BY TAKING THE TIME
TO REMEMBER AND HONOR.
ALL INDIVIDUALS TO GIVE THE GIFT
OF KNOWLEDGE THROUGH TEACHING.
THE DAY OF THE TEACHER SHOULD BE
A DAY FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
PARENTS PUBLIC OFFICIALS AND THE
COMMUNITY TO RECOGNIZE THE
DEDICATION AND COMMITMENT.
OF TEACHERS FOR EDUCATING OUR
CHILDREN.
AS A CLASSROOM TEACHER FOR
SEVENTEEN YEARS I WANTED TO
CARRY THIS RESOLUTION TO
HIGHLIGHT THE IMPORTANCE OF
TEACHERS.
MEMBERS IT HAS BEEN THE
PRIVILEGE OF MY LIFE TO BE IN
THE CLASSROOM.
AND EDUCATE THE NEXT GENERATION
OF LEADERS.
I CAN TELL YOU WITH CERTAINTY
THAT TEACHERS ARE A SPECIAL
GROUP OF PEOPLE THEY PROVIDE
FOOD.
CLOTHING MATERIALS WHEN OUR
STUDENTS NEEDED.
AND THE STATE BAN WITH PARENTS
ARE HAVING A HARD TIME.
TODAY'S TEACHERS MOLD THE MINDS
AND TRAIN THE WORKFORCE OF THE
FUTURE NO OTHER PROFESSION
TOUCHES SO MANY LIVES.
GOOD TEACHERS GROWING VALUE AND
PAY DIVIDENDS FAR BEYOND THE
CLASSROOM.
WE'VE AND TEACH ABOUT COMPOST TO
SUPPORT THE RESOLUTION BY THE
GOOD SENATOR OF CANOGA PARK.
EVERY SINGLE PERSON IN THIS
COUNTRY SHOULD HONOR AND RESPECT.
OUR TEACHERS WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THE CENTER RUBIO MEMBERS IN THE
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE. FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO AND THE
RESOLUTION PASSES MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM FIFTY THREE SENATOR
HERTZBERG MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
READ READ PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL ONE THIRTY FOUR BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG AN ACTOR IN THE WATER
CONSERVATION CENTER HERTZBERG.
THEY WERE MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT
SO LAST YEAR.
ALONG WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN WE PACKS THE PACKAGE OF
MEASURES AS PART OF A TWO YEAR
EFFORT BY THE BROWN
ADMINISTRATION TO MAKE WATER
EFFICIENCY A WAY OF LIFE.
THERE WAS SOME CONFUSION IN THE
APPLICATION OF THAT MEASURE AS
TO WHETHER OR NOT WE WOULD LOOK --
TO WATER SAVINGS ACROSS
RESIDENTIAL COMMERCIAL
INDUSTRIAL WATER LOSS IN OUTDOOR
USE THERE WAS SOME THAT LOOKED
AT INDIVIDUALLY WE RESOLVE THAT
IN THIS MEASURE WHICH DETERMINES
A STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD WILL ENFORCE A CUMULATIVE
PERFORMANCE TATTERED.
AS A RESULT THESE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN REFLECT A RESOLUTION AMONG
ALL PARTIES -- THE BILL WILL
HELP NO LONGER HAS ANY
OPPOSITION AS WE CLEAR A PATH
FORWARD TOWARD WATER RESILIENCY
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER HERTZBERG
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING THAT MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING THEM NICE
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO IN THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE'RE NOW GOING TO MOVE
ON TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
BEFORE WE TAKE THAT UP DOES
ANYONE HAVE ANYTHING THAT THEY
WOULD LIKE TO REMOVE FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING HEARING THEN MR SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL.
THREE THIRTY FOUR THERE WE GO.
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL FOR
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING THEM EYES
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
WE ARE NOW RETURNING TO MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS IS TO BE THE
APPROPRIATE TIME FOR A JOURNEY
MEMORIES [inaudible]
SENATOR BATES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT -- I
WOULD LIKE TO A JURY IN MEMORY
THIS AFTERNOON NOW -- FOR
REDUCING HIM HOFF FROM LITTLE
THEIR RANCH IN MY DISTRICT -- HE
WAS AN AMAZING YOUNG MAN HE
LOVES SPORTS COOKING PHOTOGRAPHY
AND SPENDING TIME WITH HIS
FRIENDS.
LOVED HIS FAMILY VERY MUCH
FATHER PAUL MOTHER CHRISTY
BROTHER MAX AND HIS DOG DANDER.
ON FEBRUARY TENTH TWENTY SIXTEEN
WHEN HE WAS ONLY TWELVE YEARS
OLD RE SAM HOFF WAS DIAGNOSED
WITH OSTEOSARCOMA A RARE FORM OF
BONE CANCER.
BUT IS WHEN WE'RE FORCED TO FACE
DIFFICULTIES THAT ARE TRUE
CHARACTERS REVEAL THAT'S WHY FOR
THE PAST THREE YEARS.
REESE ACQUIRED A NICKNAME THAT
FIT HIM PERFECTLY RES THE BEAST
EVERYDAY FOR THE PAST THREE
YEARS THE BEAST GOT OUT OF BED
AND THOUGHT.
HE FOUGHT THROUGH NINE SURGICAL
PROCEDURES THROUGH FIFTEEN
AGGRESSIVE CAMILLE
CHEMOTHERAPY'S THAT WOULD KNOCK
ANY GROWN MAN OFF HIS FEET HE
AMAZES DOCTORS OF HOW QUICKLY HE
WOULD GET OUT OF BED.
HIS GRANT AND PERSEVERANCE
AMAZES FRIENDS AND FAMILY EVERY
DAY FOR THE PAST THREE YEARS.
AFTER THREE YEARS THERE WERE
STILL OTHER TREATMENTS TO BE
TRIED FOR REDUCE SOME OUT OF THE
BOX IDEAS THAT HADN'T BEEN TRIED
ON ANYONE BEFORE.
BUT AFTER THREE INTENSE YEARS OF
BATTLING THE LORD KNEW THAT
REESE HAVE FOUGHT LONG AND HARD
ENOUGH.
IT WAS TIME TO BRING HIM HOME ON
MARCH TENTH TWENTY NINETEEN AT
THE MUCH TOO YOUNG AGE OF JUST
FIFTEEN YEARS.
REESE THE BEES STEM HOP WENT
HOME TO BE WITH THE LORD.
HE DEMONSTRATED TO EVERYONE THAT
KNEW HIM WHAT IT MEANS TO TRULY
NEVER EVER GIVE UP.
AT A TIME WHEN IT COULD BE EASY
AND EVEN UNDERSTANDABLE TO PLACE%
THE FOCUSED ON HIMSELF.
HE WAS STILL GO OUT OF HIS WAY
TO LOOK OUT FOR OTHERS.
HE IS A WARRIOR A FRIEND A
FIGHTER HE IS THE BEAST AND HE
WILL BE EMAILED TO ASK.
TODAY ASSN WE ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF RESUME HARPER.
AND TO SEND OUR CONDOLENCES TO
HIS FAMILY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES PLEASE
BE SURE TO BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD SO WE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED [inaudible]
SENATOR WIENER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT -- TODAY I RISE TO ASK
THAT THE SENATE ADJOURNED IN
MEMORY OF BOB LAKE LOBES PASSED
AWAY -- THIS PAST TUESDAY AFTER.
A LONG -- HE SURVIVE -- BY HIS
WIFE LISA -- AND BY HIS TWO
YOUNG CHILDREN BRIAN -- AND
AMANDA -- THIS ONE IS --
PERSONAL FOR ME AS BLAKE WAS MY
SUPERVISOR WHEN I WAS A DEPUTY
CITY ATTORNEY AND THE SAN
FRANCISCO.
THE ATTORNEYS OFFICE.
HE TAUGHT ME AN AWFUL LOT ABOUT
WHAT IT MEANT TO BE A TRIAL
ATTORNEY -- AND HE WAS A MENTOR
TO ME -- FOR MANY MANY YEARS AND
EVEN AFTER I LEFT.
THE PRACTICE OF LAW TO GOING TO
ELECTED OFFICE I WOULD.
SOMETIMES IS CALLED A CONSULT
WITH HIM ON VARIOUS LEGAL ISSUES --
PLAY BECAUSE ONE OF THE MOST.
BRILLIANT AND CREATIVE.
ATTORNEYS SOME PARTICULARLY AS A
TRIAL ATTORNEY -- THAT I EVER
MET DURING MY FIFTEEN YEARS --
THE PRACTICE OF LAW.
HE SPENT TWENTY TWO YEARS IN THE
CITY ATTORNEY'S OFFICE -- AS ONE
OF THE MOST RESPECTED ATTORNEYS
I IN THE OFFICE HE WENT INTO
PRIVATE PRACTICE AFTERWARDS --
AND HE WAS JUST ONE OF THE MOST
THOUGHTFUL AND CARING -- PEOPLE --
I'VE KNOWN AND SOMEONE WHO
REALLY -- IT HE HELD ON TO
THINGS IN THE PRESS AND IN THE
PRACTICE OF LAW AT A TIME IS
VERY DIFFICULT BECAUSE YOU DEAL
WITH DIFFICULT CASES WERE
SOMETIMES TERRIBLE THINGS HAPPEN
TO PEOPLE -- AND IT'S HARD NOT
TO HOLD ON TO IT -- BUT WE TRAIN
OURSELVES TO DO THAT.
PUBLIC LAKE NEVER -- AVOIDED --
THE HUMAN SIDE OF THE PRACTICE
OF LAW.
AND IT'S A HUGE LOSS -- TO VERY
VERY LARGE NETWORK OF PEOPLE AND
MY HEART BREAKS FOR HIS WIFE SEN --
LEADING TO YOUNG CHILDREN BEHIND
AND SO IT'S JUST JUST A TERRIBLE
TRAGEDY AND NO MATTER HOW MANY
TIMES -- WE DEAL WITH -- DEATH --
PEOPLE WHO HAVE SO MUCH AHEAD OF
THEM -- IT NEVER GETS EASIER OR
SO PLAY WE LOVE YOU SO MANY
PEOPLE LOVE YOU -- REST IN PEACE.
THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER PLEASE
BRING HIS NAME FORWARD SO WE CAN
BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED.
MEMBERS IF THERE IS NO FURTHER
BUSINESS SENATOR WELL THE DESK
IS CLEAR.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT --
VERY PRODUCTIVE DAY TODAY THE
SENATE WILL NOW BE IN RECESS
UNTIL THREE THIRTY PM AT WHICH
TIME THE GERMAN MOTION WILL BE
MADE.
AND WE WILL RECONVENE HERE BACK
ON THURSDAY NINE AM SHARP.
THANK YOU SENATOR WILK THE
SENATE WILL BE ADJOURNED AND WE
WILL RECONVENE THURSDAY AT NINE
AM HAVE A GREAT REST THE DAY
MEMBERS